good evening we now know more about the
progress of Phase two of Nevada's
reopening thanks for joining us here at
6:00 I'm Denise Feltes and I'm Kirsten
Joyce Governor Steve Sicily held a news
conference at find this evening the
i-team's Vanessa Murphy is live in the
newsroom with more on what he had to
share Vanessa the governor is saying
Nevada is not ready to move into phase 3
kovat 19 cases are going up so no
additional restrictions are being lifted
and at this point there is no date for
phase 3 as the governor's team monitors
the virus now what this means is some
businesses like bars which do not serve
food must remain closed sporting events
and concerts are not allowed to take
place and social distancing in
restaurants and face coverings for
employees inside businesses are still
mandated governor steve selects says as
the state reopens and testing increases
as predicted there is an increase in
kovat 19 cases there's been an upward
trend over the last three weeks and
contact tracing will play a major part
in figuring out specifically how people
are contracting the virus they will
learn whether the virus is spreading for
example at protests and casinos so it
comes up through what Julie had just
previously mentioned that one particular
business type has got a problem that
there's a spread in a particular
business we might look at doing
something in that area if we come up
with a situation that we can pinpoint
that there's been a spread and/or a
break out because of a certain activity
or a certain event or a certain location
those are the kind of things we could
look at the governor also confirming
there will soon be a special session
Nevada's economy is hit hard and
lawmakers will have to head to Carson
City to figure out the state budget
he also says an announcement will be
made soon on the moratorium on evictions
and foreclosures meaning we will learn
whether that will expire soon or
continue so again no timeline for Phase
three of reopening governor steve
selecting right now the state is not
ready to continue lifting restrictions
reporting live in the newsroom vanessa
murphy 8 news